Земля грузинського фермера Іллі Бервашвілі
опинилася у центрі замороженого конфлікту між Грузією
та самопроголошеною Південною Осетією, яку підтримує Росія.
На деяких картах лінія розмежування
пролягає просто через його фермерські території.
На цих зелених знаках написано "державний кордон" -
лінія, яку більшість країн світу не визнає.
Російські прикордонники патрулюють, по суті, на околиці його полів.
- Якщо перетнув цю лінію, то вони забирають, штрафують, саджають у в'язницю.
Якщо наша худоба перетинає лінію, вони забирають її.
Самі вони ходять тут і вказують нам, що й до чого.
Ходять із собаками, зі зброєю.
Постійно перебуваєш у такому психологічно підвішеному стані.
Під час війни кілька бомб впали на землю Іллі.
Його 84-річна мати розповідає, що втратила тоді одного з трьох її синів.
Вночі я іноді не можу спати,
тому що боюся за свого сина,
щоб вони не прийшли. Я боюся.
У серпні 2008 року напруга між Росією та Грузією
переросла в війну в Південній Осетії та Абхазії.
Грузія хотіла повернути контроль над Південною Осетією.
Росія відреагувала на це танками та авіаційними ударами.
Обґрунтування, як і в Криму: Кремль буцімто захищав російських громадян у регіоні.
Сьогодні російські бази розташовані в обох сепаратистських регіонах,
зокрема в Цхінвалі, де-факто столиці самопроголошеної Південної Осетії.
Спостерігачі з моніторингової місії ЄС виступають посередниками.
Вони патрулюють адміністративну лінію розмежування.
- Сам факт, що є велика кількість озброєних людей,
розташованих відносно близько один до одного уздовж лінії розмежування, -
це те, що потрібно уважно моніторити.
Особливо там, де немає спільної згоди, де саме пролягає ця лінія розмежування.
Тому ми представлені в регіоні з 200 спостерігачами цілодобово.
- Для Росії та Південної Осетії це - державний кордон.
Для Грузії це тимчасова окупаційна лінія.
А для місцевих це постійне джерело невизначеності.
У деяких місцях огородження просто відсутнє.
Невизначена лінія розмежування проковтнула й деяке майно Іллі.
Але він налаштований будь-що залишатися на своїй землі.
Ця ферма передавалася в родині з покоління у покоління.
- Мені нема куди йти. Це моя частина Грузії,
це моя частина батьківщини, я не віддам навіть одного кроку,
ані краплі нікому не віддам.
Для молодого покоління, яке живе тут, здається,
що війна десь дуже далеко в минулому.
Але допоки конфлікт не розв’язано,
загроза того, що напруга знову може перерости в бойові дії, залишається реальністю.